thank you feeder and it's an honor and a
pleasure to be here you know being in
the Symons Institute for various
programs since its inception and I think
it's valuable in bringing the community
you know bringing the not only the
theory community and looking at
interfaces with practice and you know
broadening the horizon overall not only
at Berkeley but research everywhere else
as well and so today I want to like give
a more broader high-level view of where
we are with machine learning especially
when it comes to you know like the
lessons we've learned time academia and
in theory how much of that is really
transferable to practical deployments in
industry right so what are the gaps and
what are ways we can try to overcome
that because in my academic career I've
had the pleasure and you know like also
the privilege in some sense to really
work on deeply theoretical interesting
problems especially in terms of methods
how we can take linear algebra to more
dimensions and what kind of theoretical
problems that were previously not
possible to solve could be solved with
these tensor methods
and indeed under what conditions is that
possible right but now are these
assumptions or conditions are they valid
in practice you know what kind of
problems are can be really tackled not
only with tens of methods but broadly
with algorithms we analyze in theory and
what are the other pillars I mean in
academia and in research in general we
spend a lot of time on algorithms you
know really kind of getting the last bit
of performance right no proving tight
bounds and all that's really valuable
work but in addition we need research
also on the other two pillars that's
data and compute right because when it
comes to doing AI or machine learning at
scale
in a practical setting we need all these
three right so most of the academic
research happens on data that's a
benchmark you know imagenet is the most
popular computer vision benchmark and
similarly you have in other domains as
well and so we keep repeatedly trying to
improve that and there are indeed a lot
of problems with that approach right we
would you know end up over inevitably
overfitting on those benchmarks and also
will miss the problems that are involved
with the data collection itself and then
the other pillar is infrastructure I
mean like this compute was really you
know neural networks have been around
forever right so we and there is a lot
of theoretical contributions much before
we could get them to deploy and the main
advance was really in compute and data
right whereas we have the simplest
algorithms currently being implemented
at scale in these deep neural networks
so how we can also think about the
interface of systems and machine
learning is there new research that we
can do to further optimize that
interface I mean there's still lots of
architectures and algorithms we can't
implement with our current technology
can we further try to close that gap by
thinking about what are the different
compute infrastructures and how we can
you know think of designing algorithms
but more importantly build the software
frameworks that will enable people to
try it out and further innovate and
that's kind of my broad message from
this talk that how we can bring all this
together so when I go further into what
you know problems we want to think when
it comes to data right so so the very
first question is if you don't have the
data you have to collect it right so as
I said most of our theory is with iid
samples the train and the test
distributions being the same but that's
hardly ever true in practice so we have
to and collect the data and maybe what
we collect and train our
model is very different from how we test
it or where we deploy the model so how
do we overcome those problems the other
one is like when you're collecting the
data and you want to do learning with
labels you have to have human annotators
it's typically you know human label data
that we would need to have and so the
standard paradigm is to have multiple
crowd workers so if you're hiring people
to label data there's gonna be noise so
you need to aggregate this data from
different crowd workers right so I mean
there's a lot of time and effort spent
in you know getting these crowd workers
are aggregating information from them
are there ways to optimize their alright
and finally like you know when I say
augmentation usually you know people
think of simple things like if it's only
a computer vision application crop the
image add some noise right but this is
very simple kind of way to prevent
overfitting like if you have you know if
you're training on a set of examples you
can tend to overfit and what are ways to
regularize for that but are there more
sophisticated mechanisms right so how we
can you know build more information
about what what is the process in which
the samples are generated what is the
domain knowledge we have I mean if this
is a particular domain from which the
data is collected what additional
knowledge can we bring in right can we
do more sophisticated data augmentation
and what does theory tell us and what is
practice tell us so those will be some
of the topics that I'll cover so I will
spend a lot of time on the data side but
I want to bring up like the main issues
that I've been working on on the other
two pillars as well so as Peter
mentioned when it comes to algorithms a
lot of my time and effort has been spent
on thinking about multidimensionality
like how with tensors we can go beyond
linear algebra
what kind of problems will it solve that
a matrix decomposition or matrix method
cannot all right so I will kind of skip
most of that in this talk but I'm happy
to kind of talk offline about it but I
will talk about a more recent work on
the optimization side I know so there's
a lot more work on convex optimization
because that's something we can analyze
very well in theory we can get really
sharp bounds but now with the deep
neural networks being almost you know in
in so many applications there's the need
to also push the theory for non convex
right so so non convex is almost a
misnomer because that's everything
that's not convex so that really doesn't
help us right so that'll include all the
hard problems so now the question is we
can ask okay what are the conditions
under which we can improve some
desirable or nice bounds and guarantee
success in some form but then you know
in practice can we go and check those
conditions like the prop popular
problems and popular frameworks we are
using in practice to the way satisfy
those conditions and what intuitions to
be gained from that theory and so today
I'll show you how a simple gradient
compression scheme where you just take a
sign of the gradient and use this for a
distributed optimization setting you can
analyze convergence rates in theory but
also in practice be sure how you can get
almost the same accuracy as the full SGD
model but you can save a lot on
throughput right it can be much more
efficient and faster in getting that
answer so that kind of also relates to
as I said the infrastructure side like
you you know are there algorithms in
machine learning that we can exploit
better from our computer infrastructure
because a lot of traditional hardware
and compute was designed to do exact
computation to do high precision
computation
to really have redundancy and
reliability but maybe machine learning
doesn't need all that heavy you know
infrastructure maybe there are lighter
forms of hardware and infrastructure
that could be better suited right so
there's a lot of open problems in that
area and you know indeed on the
infrastructure side I won't give a whole
lot of details in this talk but there
are a lot of questions right so the base
level like there is the the GPUs have
become the workhorse of deep learning
and the main reason is you know CUDA and
the possibility of parallel computing at
scale right like being able to really be
efficient on matrix computation like
operations those that can be paralyzed
very well and as you know deep neural
networks consist of mostly those
operations and hence we've been able to
deploy them at scale but even there
there are questions of can we go beyond
the current primitives that exists there
and can we think of you know what's the
kind of natural for me is to ask what
are the tensor primitives or
higher-order primitives that could make
it even better so there are a lot of
interesting questions there on what you
know hardware primitives can help us
realize different machine learning
methods and that's kind of like on the
platform layer right where you want to
be able to use this compute and easily
design different neural network
architectures quickly define you know
different models you want to run and be
able to just easily deploy them at scale
without worrying about the lower level
primitives and frameworks like tensor
flow and PI Taj have been very important
to you know make this jump right
otherwise earlier when it came to doing
research it was just very hard and
complex to do all this programming so
this abstraction helped a lot and then
in industry what's really happening and
emerging is to build applications on top
of it so
make it even easier in terms of
consuming the results of machine
learning so you have the recognition API
from AWS or the vision API from Google
Cloud or you have the automotive drive
service from Nvidia so these are all
services that you know are either for
one application or one domain and the
machine learning models are pre-trained
and they're serving different customers
right so so as you can imagine here many
of the fundamental assumptions we make
in our machine learning theory is
violated because the model is trained on
a different data than where it is third
and maybe you want to serve different
customers with different needs so there
are a lot of new interesting problems we
can ask also from the theoretical angle
on how to tackle such scenarios so
overall that's kind of the theme of how
all these three pillars come together
and what we can do to put you know have
a unified thinking of all of them and by
the way feel free to interrupt me I like
this to be interactive just how I like
my machine learning as well so so feel
free to ask questions anytime great so
now let's go further into the data part
so what are some mechanisms to make our
first data collection more efficient and
ultimately also our algorithm small
sample efficient so the first aspect is
how we can you know learn actively and
learn with different kinds of simple
feedback compared to standard passive
learning and full feedback and as I said
the more emphasis is on how in more you
know common empirical problems how much
of savings do we get from some of the
simplest schemes right so there's indeed
long research being done in each of this
by the focuses how this is helping
improve the latest deep learning models
and Wow
lessons to be learned from that so as I
said the second part will be on
aggregation if you have multiple crowd
workers how do you aggregate the data
and you know get a good machine learning
model so typically what's the kind of
time they're thinking here you would
like you know you would like your each
data sample to be as nice free as
possible so that's why you have many
annotators per sample so you try to
reduce the noise in each sample right
but what we'll show is this is not
needed if you ultimately want to model
that strain well so you can get away
with a lot of noise at each sample level
and so there are good as long as you can
also incorporate the label noise into
your overall framework this is okay and
then in the last part as I said I'll
cover how with generative modeling you
can do better semi-supervised learning
and also think about how to you know how
does generation and prediction kind of
go with each other right so mostly we
think about supervised learning we think
about prediction generation is a much
harder problem and usually that kind of
the two areas are decoupled right but
we'll try to couple them together and
ask is there a model that both jointly
generates and predicts and does well in
prediction I mean always you can use one
model to do the other but to do it well
is the key and then in the second part
it will be more about asking can we use
incorporate the domain knowledge as well
into our learning and we'll do it in a
very specific form if there are symbolic
rules or expressions how do we use that
to also incorporate in our kind of
function approximation kind of paradigm
right so there is additional information
not just an input and output framework
for learning so what can be done there
so that's the broad ideas like you know
when it's so this is all the three
stages right you want to color
the data then you want to clean up the
data and make it ready for machine
learning and ultimately when you're
learning you want to augment it because
without that you end up overfitting
almost in practice if you no matter how
good your data is most likely we would
have to do additional augmentation just
by itself is not enough right it's it's
something simple like dropout or some
regularization but you know can it be
more sophisticated than much worse
these areas will explore great so now
you know so what does active learning
give us so what is the basic idea of
active learning right so you know
instead of just going and labeling all
the examples we are asking you know can
you tell me what examples will be most
useful for training this model right and
intuitively it's it'll be those examples
where the current model is uncertain
about so the most basic active learning
algorithm goes through uncertainty
sampling so you have a current model
that is trained and then you look at how
certain is this model on these you know
my new on labeled samples and then you
take only the uncertain our samples
label them retrain the model and do this
again and again so this is the most
popular form of active learning you know
there are positive results as well as
negative results for that right and then
they're more sophisticated ones so our
first question was you know how will
this work well with some of the you know
standard deep learning frameworks and
then the other question was you know
when could this possibly fail and what
else can we do there so for the first
part what we took was this task of named
in our state of art the state of the art
like the
yeah that's never issue so yeah so can
you reach the best performance but we're
doing smaller data set thank you any
others yeah yeah so the named entity
recognition is a sequence tagging task
also you have text you want to ask you
know can I tag whether each shout piece
of each token or a word is what entity
it is and whether it's an entity and
what type it is
right so there are standard neural
network models for this I won't go into
it we also did some innovation so on the
architecture side but that details are
in the paper but the main kind of you
know question was you know so we did the
least confidence sampling so in this
case we were taking sentences right and
so we were asking okay we'll take this
sentence with the least confidence and
we'll go ahead and label it and we
simulated the labeling on this biggest
open benchmark what's called on two
nodes and so that was the least
confident sampling the other was
normalizing it for the length so the
intuition is longer sentences will all
you know always tend to have the lower
confidence right if you have more words
naturally the confidence of tagging all
of them correctly will be lower so
instead if we normalize for the length
then we can you know because the effort
is usually at the token level if you go
and ask the annotator
so we felt this was a fairer heuristic
for saying which you know how to label
it better and so what we see here is the
you know so the main result is you can
get away with much smaller number of
samples to get the state-of-the-art
results so if you're actively sample
with very simple least confidence or
normalized least confidence heuristics
you can do with just 25% of the original
data right and so that's that's nice so
you know like deep learning you think
who requires a lot of samples but with
active learning there's a potential to
reduce it further and
then the other question was I mean like
shallow models Turek you know can work
very well with small amount of data so
and deep models require more but if deep
models have the you know freedom to do
this active sampling then can can it
beat the shallow model at what number of
samples will it beat that and it turns
out that with very little data the deep
model is already beating the shallow one
right and even when the shallow model is
given all the data so we were more than
fair to the shallow model yeah so
possibly I mean there's a slight like
kind of fierce going above the curve I
mean yeah it's it's a good question
right so it is kind of you know like it
is following a different optimization
pact so so possibly it's doing better at
least in that case it is but more
universally I don't know yeah yeah it
was like a CRF it was like this you know
the best one and for that problem that I
forget the details but it's the kind of
the one that people use the most before
deep learning came about yeah and yeah
so you know like the popular wisdom is
when there is less data do classical
machine learning only if you have more
label data do deep learning right but
that could be overcome if you have the
ability to query actively and label
actively then there is the potential of
making deep learning work even with less
data so that was the kind of finding
from this work that you know it's
possible to drastically reduce this but
there is also a corollary that I want to
point out that this was on a you know
popular benchmark and all these
benchmarks right like kind of we are
currently judging only based on the size
of it like this is the largest one so
people think
the most difficult benchmark but what
this was saying was really the you know
the kind the amount of information
present in this right the the Dom on
that active learning requires is like a
surrogate of like the diversity of this
benchmark right it gives your point of
measure for that so so maybe this would
be another you know outcome of using
active learning is to be able to judge
which benchmark data sets are actually
diverse and goods so because if you have
like a lot of difficulty on this data
set maybe you do even if you're doing it
actively you would end up requiring more
samples so that's something to really
think about right yes I mean so so the
way we did this was you know so we're
actually like kind of doing mini batch
training so you do have like the old
data and then you know you're not like
looking at all the unlabeled one right
so that's not efficient so so we are
instead of like kind of randomly
subsampling and within that choosing
like you know the words yes so it's like
that's where the labeling you know the
the cost is in terms of the words and so
because that's how it's done
in NLP so that was the take away with
this that active learning can
potentially reduce and also have a
mechanism to evaluate the diversity of
datasets so the next work what we asked
was that's great that we do selection of
data actively but can we also select the
questions and the kind of feedback
actively right so typically if you have
a large number of craft class
in practice you would need some
structure and the hierarchy is the most
natural one in many cases for instance
in imagine that you have a hierarchy of
the classics right so you have like kind
of whether it's an animal or not and
then a dog and so on so you have you
know you're given this hierarchy and
that's how you send this out to the
annotator
right so you're asking binary questions
to the annotator and that way you get to
the finest category because it's like if
you think of a user interface you can't
just like have a drop-down menu and just
give all the finest categories and ask
them to pick one right so the only one
that's feasible with a large number of
classes is through binary questions so
for hierarchy and so if that's the set
up then we can ask you know can I now
you know actively select what to ask the
user right so so indeed like as you know
a Misha you are learning something more
it would be wasteful to ignore that so
if the model is already confident that
this is an animal you can then ignore
this first set of questions and directly
drill down further right so so you want
to figure out where in the hierarchy
you're reasonably confident and we're
the best reduction in uncertainty is
right by choosing that and the other
thing is to be more from you know like
saving in resources you know you don't
have to wait to label your sample
completely you can now say let me go
actively find another sample ask another
question and keep moving on so I can
keep just getting a partial answers on
each data point but then I'm training
the model right so ultimately with the
model I can go back and lie label all my
training examples my test examples and
so on and so the so this was the
question like how much saving can we get
by doing both data and feedback actively
and it turns out it's quite a lot you
can save so with so the ELA curve is
with both data and questions actively
and you can see like
that was more than it was higher
accuracy so we even got like kind of
similar to the earlier point right like
active learning could also help you get
better accuracy so we're getting higher
accuracy is here but also with less
number of questions or feedback so I
just thirty percent of the questions
compared to a passive uniform sampling
so and then there are the intermediate
schemes so what here so we use a number
of different mechanisms ultimately like
entropy you know or uncertainty once
there was not that much of a difference
between them so it's kind of like you
know ultimately like kind of they were
all having similar performance I mean so
these are like kind of you know so on
this imaginary data set right so this is
like reaching the the same as you as you
had like kind of 100 percent of the
samples right so so that's the best
performance on this like a subsample on
this data Sergius on this kind of sub
sampled image net and then you know we
can further scale up and ask what it is
Yeah right so here so far we have only
like kind of simulated labeling right so
now if it is a real system there's the
latency of sending out the data and then
it's the question of like okay how much
of the pool of data do I send and
there's also a learning is now with
mini-batches right so there's continuous
learning as well so can you try to merge
those streams so there are a lot of like
systems questions as well how do you
design that whole mechanism and and
that's why I like kind of even now there
isn't like kind of a nice mechanism to
do it online right so most of it is you
know it's all offline right now and so
there is latency but there are you know
there is potential so there that's an
open problem great so that was on the
you know the takeaway from the active
learning side that when positive you
know if active learning is possible
do you know go for it like go actively
label your data but also actively ask
your questions and don't wait to
completely label your each data point
but keep moving on and that way you can
learn faster and so since then my
collaborator Zack Lipton at CMU has
further investigated right like the
question of transferability of actively
collected data so if you're now have
this data set that's collected actively
for one task how transferable it is
right and the other question is if you
are doing active learning in practice
you cannot set the hyper parameters you
know many times on the same data set
right but I mean the main challenge is
to prevent overfitting
so which active learning methods are
less prone to overfitting and which ones
are not
and it turns out like a more Bayesian
framework a bayesian disagreement
framework is more robust when you also
do extensive experimentation although
like in these limited ones the two
didn't show that much of a difference
and that's why there's a need to always
kind of keep doing further
empirical studies to really tease out
the differences between different
algorithms so that was on the active
learning side the next question we asked
was on the crowd side like if you now
have a you know set of crowd workers
giving you labels you know some people
can be expert in one category in other
I'm different one right so they can be
error-prone and so how do you merge all
their answers so the most standard thing
is to take the majority rule like you
know it's the wisdom of the cloud and
you go with that we've just seen that
play out time politics and it's always
nowadays the best thing and so probably
you know maybe majority is not the right
thing to do all right so can we do about
it what are the other alternatives so
what people usually do in practice is to
have like a gold standard data set a
small amount of label samples that is
done by experts so that you know that's
correct and then use the crowd workers
and then try to evaluate how good they
are right but even this has a
disadvantage because you only can
evaluate on a small number so really the
you know this is a latent variable
estimation problem because we don't know
what the ground truth label is right we
don't know what the correct answer is so
we have all these noisy labels from the
crowd workers how do we estimate both
the ground truth and as well as the
confusion matrices of the crowd workers
so so how do we do both at the same time
so I mean one kind of simple starting
point is maybe you start like you know
you look at the disagreement with the
majority and then try to improve it
right so if you ask like how far are you
from the majority they'll give you like
a accuracy of each worker and then based
on that you you know you can try to do
that and that's what some of the
previous works did but this is still a
problem because you're going with the
majority so let me just come to what we
did so what we instead
you know the main intuition is we
ultimately want our machine learning
model to be good right our machine
learning model should be close to the
ground truth labels so if we get to a
point where we have very good estimates
of how accurate the crowd workers are as
well as a good machine learning model
then you know then we have achieved our
goal so at that point you can ask the
machine learning model is this crowd
worker correct or not
right so we can like play this game of
iterative learning where in the
beginning we're gonna pretend that all
the crowd workers are perfect and then
based on that train our machine learning
model and then we'll ask the machine
learning model how is in each crowd
worker differing from your answer right
so that's your current estimates of the
errors made by the crowd worker so you
can use that to do a weighted loss
minimization you can go back and forth
like this and so the idea is you know if
you start at a reasonably good point you
can improve each other
so your estimate of how good the crowd
workers are improves and your machine
learning model also improves so overall
you will get better right and that's
kind of what we showed both in theory
and in practice so in theory are the
question we addressed was suppose you
have a fixed budget you know it's like
the amount of annotations you get is
fixed right do allocate more workers for
each sample or do you label more right
so what the traditional wisdom was you
really want more workers for each sample
because you really want it to be nice
rate but here in our framework we are
incorporating the label noise into our
framework we are doing this iterative
mechanism so we are incorporating and
that you know we are aware there is
label noise right so in that setting it
turns out that having just single
annotation per sample is ok so even if
it's error at a prone it's okay overall
you will train a good model with that
which will generalize well
and that's what we found in practice as
well so here again the main challenge
was really getting a data set then you
know like the theory was great but
getting the data set was the challenge
because most open data sets throw away
you know the information about who they
are how you know which annotators
labelled wort and who the other
annotators are whereas for Microsoft Co
Co we got this information and that's
how we could show the improvement yeah
yeah yes so this is right so the theory
here you're assuming like you know how
the crowd workers are you know this is a
this is still a simplistic assumption
right so you're saying that the crowd
workers are making independent errors
and you have a predictor in the class
that is good right that's right that's
accurate so yeah I'm a close to that
yeah yeah I mean like nearly like kind
of the probability we have like
thresholds and we have different
settings so you know so there isn't
either set of assumptions and there's
always room to further reprove that yeah
so the main you know kind of outcome of
this was to you know potentially like
take you know design a better framework
that is aware of how the data collection
and aggregation is happening right
instead of keeping that separate from
machine learning training you're
combining that and because of that you
can save a lot in the number of samples
you can save a lot in the annotation
efforts so that was kind of the outcome
of this so I'll kind of the rest of it
I'll be much quicker because I realize
I'm you know coming closer to the times
but I want to give you some you know
high-level intuitions of what we can do
in these frameworks so the generative
modeling you know the Gann or generative
adversarial networks have been the
popular class so where you know there's
like feedback you're getting on weather
images fake or not using another
discriminator your training and based
all that you're trying to generate right
but this is a lot of issues I won't go
into it but kind of my primary goal as I
said is to do data augmentation so I
want to be able to you know better
regularize the data better come up with
even training mechanisms for supervised
learning or semi-supervised learning and
so how do we do that
so the main idea was kind of can we have
one model to do both right so the
generative model is like trying to
generate for each category you know like
what the images if it's an image example
so the prediction is given the image
what is the label right so we want to
like kind of ask is there one model that
is good in both right so and that's a
hard one indeed to generate is really
hard because you're losing information
when you try to go from image to label
so so what we wanted to ask was you know
for prediction we know that
convolutional neural networks are the
state of art models for computer vision
so is there a generative model such that
when we you know do inference in this
model can we recover the convolutional
neural network right what is the
mechanism that allows that right so the
basically the idea is now you're going
from your object category to the image
and you're going through intermediate
steps of rendering right but indeed this
process is not going to be certain right
it's not deterministic because if you
say a dog there are all possible kinds
of dogs right so you do want to have
random variables but the key is how do
you design these random variables and so
the main sorry so the main idea is we
try to reverse the convolutional neural
network right so when you think of what
the convolutional neural network is
doing it's doing convolution then it's
doing like pooling which reduces the
dimension and then there's some
non-linearity and so on so whereas in
generation you're going from now
court resolution to a final resolution
so that's you're increasing the
dimension and in the process what you're
doing is you're introducing random
variables because this is not a
reversible process right you can when
you do max pool in your you know losing
information but you can ask what is the
prior distribution that will you know
kind of mirror this and that'll reverse
this and so that's how we design a
structured prior for generating so the
details are in the paper I mean we in
fact also come up with a better training
mechanism for this but you know the main
intuition is we can now regularize
better so if we now have a model that's
both trying to predict but also we are
looking at you know optimizing for
likelihood for generation you know
intuitively there is a better
regularization mechanism that's
happening and it turns out that it also
gives rise to a generalization bound
that depends on the generation process
so if you assume for the class of models
that uses this generative process so
what's a good generalization is a model
that has a small number of rendering
paths so you have a small number of
paths to actively render and so you can
also you know come up with kind of you
know questions on what are bounds that
will be for this specific class of
distributions you know that kind of can
give more insights on how we design this
and in fact this will give us a new form
of regularization that also improves in
practice right so so the main idea here
was to really you know think of this
point that you know we usually do only
the convolutional network or a
feed-forward network but can we also
simultaneously have another feedback
network that will you know that will
kind of correspond to each other it's a
probabilistic distribution such that
when you do inference you recover your
convolutional network and so its
coupling the two and you know it does a
state of the art and semi-supervised
learning with that
mechanism and so there's lots of
opportunities I think to ask can we do
better generative modeling by utilizing
such information any questions here so
it's not great for visual I know kind of
a quality right because that was not the
goal of this the goal was to ask you
know whether we can so I believe we
would still need adversarial loss to
improve visual quality but but it
improved the results in terms of
semi-supervised learning yes yes
so it's injected at each level so the
main intuition is so you know you kind
of decide in each activation whether you
want to copy it down or not right so
what we call render forward and then you
know the reverse of max pooling is like
a translation process so you you want to
like randomly decide where you want to
translate within a box so it's really
like kind of now you're you know so if
you think of it that's kind of like
reversing the relu and the max pooling
so it's so that's what's happening at
each level and then there is prior that
kind of jointly models all those native
variables at all the layers but yeah
yeah so this is likelihood right so will
optimize for the likelihood
great so so that was you know so that's
how we can you know think of design of
generating models to do better soup
semi-supervised learning as well as
better supervised learning right so in
the other framework the main kind of
what is the main idea the idea was if
you try to learn each function by itself
you wouldn't need enough samples right
and not just that you're just doing
interpolation you can only tell what's
in between you can't extrapolate but if
you want to learn an entire domain of
functions I mean now what people call
meta learning I mean a lot of things are
meta learning maybe this is also metal
learning right so you learn an entire
domain of functions then you can utilize
more information right really how these
functions are related to one another and
think of very simple things like maybe
the class of trigonometric functions and
some basic algebra right so there's lots
of you know we can we have the basic
axioms and then based on that we can
generate all kinds of symbolic
relationships between them but how do we
have both you know symbolic
relationships as well as just numerical
data like you look at how the function
is at different points can you do both
together and what is the benefit of
doing that and so what we see here is
you know you can use three LST amps so
these are frameworks that you know try
to have the hierarchy and then learn
like an embedding it each level of the
hierarchy right so if you have like kind
of now symbolic equations like sine
squared plus cos square is one you can
write it as a symbolic tree right
usually we don't think of numbers or
strings right but in reality they are if
you think of a decimal representation or
any base representation right so you can
also represent numbers through like the
operation of trees and so and now if
you're evaluating functions that's also
a tree right so you are kind of
incorporating like each cell step in the
process of either evaluating a function
or represent
a number as a tree and so all these
operations have commonalities across
these different trees right and that's
what we want to try to learn so so when
we say multiplication or power or all
this right it has the you know we know
what it is because we've designed it
right but if the neural network has to
learn it just from data it will figure
out oh it's doing something common
across these different data types and
different examples so that way it's able
to learn the common relationships right
so here the point was not to program
these functions right but if you can
just learn it just based on a few axioms
and numerical data and it turns out that
by encoding it this way by also thinking
of numbers through trees and expressions
through trees you can ask about
generalizing to a higher depth so if you
only train on trees up to let's say
depth 3 and you wanna test on functions
of depth 4 that's a harder problem right
typically we don't do that in machine
learning we think of the Train and the
test as similar distributions but
because we are doing meta learning on
this entire class of functions it turns
out that you can it's possible to do
this with reasonably high accuracy and
so the main message is by thinking about
how to what are the common structures
across different kinds of information
and data you have it may be possible to
learn better and that's what this work
showed that indeed like by learning all
the functions together you can get much
better evaluation of functions right but
also more importantly you can also
improve your symbolic evaluation so if
you are giving numerical data to your
model it's more evidence of these
symbolic relationships so you can also
further evaluate functions better and
this evaluation was done on a higher
depth so you're also able to I mean
ultimately right you want a reason about
harder problems by training on simple
ones but you know current machine
learning is very bad on those so this is
one mechanism at least in this setting
where you can represent functions and
your input as trees it's possible
to be modular and try to learn better
till I was the kind of the message of
this work any quick questions here yes
yes right I mean it should be both right
that's that's kind of my goal to really
you know talk about both the you know
sites and what are the gaps and how we
can try to overcome so yes both sides
for sure yeah yes and so I mean indeed
like that is I mean this falls in the
area of neural programming right so
there is so we have some other papers on
also learning about code with the
abstract syntax trees and more so
there's some something more you would
need to do but yes that's a general
principle yeah right I mean indeed that
would be you know so we didn't evaluate
for that but there are others who kind
of you know I think followed up and did
that yes indeed that would be a you know
that would be an application of this
yeah so I mean and now we are doing
other things like PDEs and other solvers
the question is can we add both symbolic
you know information as well as
numerical data and some you know some
methods are known somewhere on you know
just based on numerical evaluation right
so there are lots of or you know things
we can take it further from this example
yeah so are we really okay was it not
five ten it was five
oh is that doing okay so so given that
this is the very end let me just very
quickly go to the end
yeah so one is like you know I just
wanted to you know have a call-out on
what I've recently started doing at in
media there is a lot of rich you know
research environment there traditionally
it's been more on graphics and
architecture and hardware and
programming but now there's a lot of
interest for machine learning robotics
computer vision so I just joined two
weeks ago but there's also others like
DITA Fox Anya fiddler who are recent
hires so there's really a lot of you
know push towards open publishable
research as well as to look at
interdisciplinary research across all
different areas right so so if you're
interested I'm definitely happy to chat
more and to conclude I mean there is you
know there are mainly three facets we
think in machine learning right the
algorithms is the central pillar when it
comes to research and analysis but data
and compute infrastructure are also
equally important to get it to practical
gains and so can we think of more
research as well both in theory and in
empirical research that takes all these
three into account together right so why
focused a lot of data primarily because
it's also I would say the biggest pain
point in most industrial applications so
more research on how we can have sample
efficient algorithms how we can have
better generalization better you know
annotation mechanisms that would be I
think very impactful so I didn't talk
about the algorithm side but I encourage
you to look up the sign SGD paper which
also talks about how gradient
compression which is seemingly lossy in
information can still achieve the same
accuracy levels
the full precision stochastic gradient
descent but give you a lot of gains when
it comes to throughput and we also have
software frameworks for tensor algebra
tensor Lior tensor ly with an ly in the
end is the framework that makes it easy
for you to add layers with tensor
computations into your neural networks
but also to do just tensor computation
in numpy if that's all you want to do
right so it's an easy front-end if you
don't like kind of programming all the
details is there for you to use and
hopefully that'll lead to exploration of
more interesting and better
architectures for neural networks
through tensor algebra and this work was
and others were plausible due to a long
list of collaborators that I worked over
the past two years
something very lucky and happy to have
been working with them thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]